[LOGO SOUNDS]
NANCY KANWISHER: So I'm doing
another one of these big mongo
lectures that
takes a whole week,
so this is really a
continuation of last time.
This is the outline
for the whole week.
We got through most of the
stuff on face perception.
I'll do some more today.
We're right there.
And we're going to go on and
consider this question of,
what's innate, and how
do you wire up brains?
So first, a brief recap of
main points from last time.
What, if anything, is innate
about face perception?
We considered lots of different
kinds of evidence, behavioral
and neural.
And the bottom line is,
maybe not that much.
So there's a few things
that are sort of suggestive,
like newborns have this
bias to look at faces more
than other non-face
stimuli that are
pretty similar-- schematic
faces versus scrambled schematic
faces.
And that's suggestive.
But then there's the
possibility that that's
just due to some very,
very simple property
of those stimuli, namely
just having more junk
on the top than the bottom, like
eyes on the top than bottom.
So what would have to
be innate in that case
would be just the simplest
possible template, not even
a whole face.
Similarly, we showed
that there's actually
very good discrimination
of one face from another,
even across viewpoint
changes in newborn humans,
and also in monkeys that
were raised without ever
being allowed to see faces.
And both of those things
suggest innate abilities
to process faces,
but in both cases,
it's possible to argue that
that ability isn't due to face
mechanisms in particular.
It's due to just general
vision and shape perception.
Third, I showed you
beautiful recent data
showing that the face
patches in monkeys
don't develop if
monkeys are reared
without ever seeing faces.
Which also suggests that
maybe not that much is innate.
So all that is fine,
but then there's
a big, wide open
question that's left
unanswered by all
of that, which is,
how do the face areas know to
land right there in everybody,
robustly?
That really feels
like something has
to be innate about
the brain, at least,
to say where those
things should go.
OK, so one possibility that
I'm sort of skipping over,
because it's a whole
little universe,
and there isn't an answer yet--
people are working on it right
now, people in this building
are working on it right now,
but the gist of the idea
is that maybe what's innate
is some other kind of
simpler selectivity.
Maybe like selectivity
for curved things.
Remember how I talked about,
as you go up the visual system,
you start with selectivity for
spots of light and then edges?
Well, maybe up
there, you're born
with selectivity
for curved things,
or something like that,
that is face-like enough
that somehow that leads
face selectivity to land
there later.
It's kind of vague because
nobody really knows,
but that's an idea.
Another possibility that we'll
talk more about in a moment
is a possibility that the reason
your face patches land right
there is something about
the long-range structural
connectivity of that region
to the rest of the brain
makes that the right place.
And so all of this is very
actively being investigated,
and nobody knows the
right answer here.
Further, I just want to mention
that deep net modeling is just
very suddenly in the last year
become a very powerful way
to approach these same questions
from a different angle.
So with deep nets, you
can ask, what do you
need to build into a network to
get it to produce face patches?
So that's a way of
asking, in principle,
in a network where you can
actually control everything
about its architecture and
about the stimuli it sees,
what are the necessary
conditions for it to produce
something like face patches?
What do you have to
train it on to get
it to produce face patches, and
to be able to recognize faces?
And at the top level, why,
computationally, does it
make sense to have face
patches in the first place?
This is kind of the
biggest question
lurking in the background
of this whole field.
I'm describing all of these
specialized mechanisms
in mind and brain, but
really, wouldn't it
be nice to know why our minds
and brains are organized
that way, rather than
just that they are?
And that's a really
hard question,
and I think there's
a real hope now
that computational modeling
may get us toward an answer
sometime in the next decade,
maybe even the next few years.
OK, so that's the overview.
I now want to go on quite a
discussion about this notion
that preexisting connectivity
may be a major constraint
in wiring up the brain.
So first, we need
to talk about, how
would you look at structural
connectivity in human brains?
And I haven't really
talked about this yet.
The main method for
being able to look--
for being able to get some
sense of this in human brains
is to use another
kind of MRI imaging.
Uses the same machine
that's an MRI machine,
but it's going to produce
anatomical images that show us
not those nice pretty pictures
of brains that you're used to,
but that show us the
direction of water diffusion.
And so the principle
is pretty simple.
Here is a picture
of an optic tract.
And what it's showing
you is that if you see,
an optic tract is a
whole bunch of axons
oriented like this connecting
retinal ganglion cells to what?
Where do the retinal
ganglion cell axons
land going through
the optic tract?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: LOG?
NANCY KANWISHER: LGN.
LGN.
Lateral geniculate
nucleus of the thalamus.
So there's that fiber bundle.
But the main point
for now is that you
can see that each
of those fibers
has a layer of fat around it,
and the upshot of all of that
is that water likes
to diffuse more
in this direction
than that direction.
That's the key idea
of diffusion imaging.
It tells you which direction
water is diffusing most.
Water is constrained by the
fat layers around those axons,
that myelin.
And so you get diffusion
more in this direction
than orthogonally to it.
And so the details
of the physics
of this kind of imaging, which
I'm totally not explaining,
are such that what
you get out is
a picture at each point
in the brain of what
is the direction of maximum
diffusion at that point.
And so here's a
little picture of lots
of little vectors
saying, at this point,
water wants to diffuse
this way, or this way,
or this way, or this way.
Everybody with me so far?
So you get a whole bunch
of little teeny vectors
all through the brain showing
you the orientation where water
wants to diffuse at that point.
And the idea is
that's telling us
which way fibers are
going at that point.
And we can therefore infer--
we can follow these things using
a method called tractography,
where we just follow
those little vectors
through the brain.
And that's what's happened here.
At each point in the brain,
you start at one point,
and you just follow these
vectors and see where they go.
Does that make sense,
sort of intuitively?
I'm skipping over
lots of details,
but I want you to get the gist.
OK, so these beautiful pictures
that you may have seen before
are diffusion tractography.
They show you our best guess
of the long-range connections
between one part of
the brain and another
based on diffusion tractography.
And on the theory
that you should
wear your data
whenever possible,
here's mine from my lab.
Whoops, I'm tangling it here.
So-- I love these things,
they're so beautiful.
One of my post-docs who's
our tractography whiz
gave me this beautiful scarf.
Isn't this nice?
And so you can see
even more clearly here
that this is a cross-section
through the brain in this axis
right here.
And so these big green
guys are the connections
that go from the back of the
head down the temporal lobe,
down the visual
pathway that we've
been talking about all along.
OK, that was gratuitous.
I just thought it was fun.
OK, so tractography is cool.
It makes gorgeous pictures
and gorgeous scarves.
And it works really well to
discover big fiber bundles.
There are lots of parts
of the brain I showed you
with that gross
dissection picture
last time, that there are
big chunks of white matter
where lots and lots of
parallel fibers go like this.
And tractography works
well to find those.
You can really see those very
nicely with diffusion imaging.
However, it's not so hot for
discovering finer connections.
It's better than
nothing, but there's
a lot of ways in which it fails.
So for example, if
you have water--
if you have fibers
crossing in some part
of the brain like this,
you'll get diffusion
in this direction
and this direction,
and the tractography
algorithm will be finished.
It won't know whether
to keep going straight
or whether to turn.
So that's just one
of many reasons why
diffusion tractography
is lovely, and wonderful,
and the best we have in in-vivo
brains, but it's not so great.
Anyway, it's all we
have, so we use it.
OK.
So we can use tractography
to ask, for example,
is the long-range connectivity
of the fusiform face
area distinct from the
long-range connectivity
of its neighbors?
In other words, on this idea
that that patch of cortex
gets wired up to be a
face area, somehow because
of the connectivity to
and from that region
to other parts of
the brain, then we
should predict that
that region should
have different connectivity
than neighboring cortex.
Otherwise, connectivity
isn't enough of a signature
to tell us where
to put a face area.
I'm seeing blank looks.
Is this not making sense?
OK.
Just butt in and ask questions
if I'm not making sense.
OK.
So question is, do these
connectivity fingerprints
predict the location of
functional regions, first
in adults?
If we don't see it in
adults, then the jig's up.
So let's start with adults.
OK.
So the way that you can
do this is, for each voxel
in the brain--
this is a big one,
so you can see it.
It would actually be
a couple millimeters,
wouldn't show on this picture.
What you do is you follow
that tractography and you say,
oh, look, it went there, and it
goes there, and it goes there.
And you tally how often,
when you start here,
you land in each of a bunch of
different big anatomical chunks
of brain.
That gives you a description
of the connectivity fingerprint
of that voxel.
How strong is its
connection to each
of these other remote
regions in the brain?
That's what I mean by a
connectivity fingerprint.
So now the question
is, can you use
this connectivity
fingerprint to predict what
the function of that voxel is?
That is, is the connectivity
distinctive enough that,
just based on diffusion
data, we could
say, what does that voxel do?
If the fusiform face area has a
whole distinctive connectivity
fingerprint, then we should
be able to predict it.
Does this make sense?
OK, so that's the question.
And there's a lot of
math, which I'll skip.
I'll just give you the gist.
So what we're trying
to figure out is,
is the fusiform face area
distinct from its neighbors
in its long-range connectivity?
That's the question.
And, in fact, it is.
And we can show that.
Again, I'm skipping
over some details,
but here is a recently-published
paper that shows you
in ways that should
be familiar now,
this is functional
MRI activation
for faces versus objects.
Fusiform face area,
that's probably
occipital face area, another
region we'll talk about later.
The face patches.
The usual face patches.
Again, this is an
inflated brain,
so the dark bits
are the bits that
used to be folded
up inside the sulcus
until they were
mathematically inflated.
So that's the standard
thing we've been looking at.
This is the prediction based
on diffusion tractography
alone in the same subject about
where the face patches should
be.
So very roughly, what you do is
you take some other subjects,
and you train them up on
connectivity fingerprints--
it's kind of like NVPA, but
you train from diffusion data,
and you try to predict
face selectivity.
And then you take the diffusion
data from a new subject,
and you predict where that
face selectivity should be,
and there's where it's
predicted for the same subject,
and it's pretty damn good.
Did everybody get the gist
of what I just went through?
You don't need to
remember every detail.
The key idea is, is there
a systematic relationship
between long-range
connectivity of a voxel
and its function,
its selectivity?
And this says yes for faces.
OK?
So that's the case for faces.
That tells us that in
adults, those face regions
have distinct connectivity.
This is the same thing.
I just shrunk it so I
could fit in other stuff.
Here is doing the
same thing for scenes.
Functional selectivity PPA
RSC, functional selectivity
for scenes measured
with functional MRI,
predicted functional pattern
from the same subject
with just tractography alone.
OK?
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NANCY KANWISHER: It's
pretty good, isn't it?
Yeah, yeah.
No, I was dissing diffusion.
You might be thinking, OK, I was
dissing diffusion tractography.
It sucks.
It has all these problems.
It has all these ambiguities.
So how could it work so well?
That's a good question.
I don't know the answer to that.
I think in part,
it's because you're
predicting based on all of
these different connections.
So even if half
of them are wrong,
you can still get some
predictive power out of it.
That's just my guess.
OK?
OK, so it works pretty
well for scenes,
and it works pretty well for
body selectivity as well.
Functional MRI prediction
from connectivity.
So that's cool.
So that says, these all
have distinct connectivity
fingerprints, but now this
is all done in adults.
And remember, the way we got
into this long shaggy dog story
is to ask what these long-range
connections, what role they
might play in development.
Remember that I said
last time that most
of the long-range connections of
the brain are present at birth.
So that suggests that maybe
these connections are also
there at birth.
And it suggests that maybe
indeed those connections could
play a role in development.
At least they're probably there.
They're in a position
to play that role,
if that's actually what happens.
So all of this brings us to
the case of rewired ferrets.
What?
What am I talking about?
They're cute, aren't they?
They're also very good
experimental animals
to address just this question.
And Mriganka Sur
in this department
did this very important
paper a while back
where he asked whether
connectivity instructs
functional development.
That is, whether the
connectivity present at birth
is sufficient to determine the
function of the region that
has those connections.
And he did this by
manipulating connectivity.
So if you want to ask,
what is the causal role
of x, you have to manipulate x.
So we've talked a lot
about this in this class.
Functional MRI, wonderful.
You see activity.
You have no idea what its causal
role is until you mess with it.
For example, by electrically
stimulating the brain.
Similarly, connectivity
may be present at birth,
and may predict where we may
be able to use it to predict
where the functions land.
It doesn't tell us that
it's playing a causal role.
The way to find out if
it's playing a causal role
is to change it and
see what happens.
And that's what Mriganka
Sur and his colleagues did.
So they used ferrets because
they're born very prematurely.
And so what that means is
that you can operate on them
surgically right at
birth before they
have any visual experience.
They haven't opened
their eyes yet.
And you can--
turns out-- reroute
some of the connectivity.
OK, so this is a diagram of some
bits that should be familiar.
The retina going to the lateral
geniculate nucleus and then
up to V1.
Also true in ferrets.
In addition, we have primary
auditory cortex that we'll
talk more about in a few weeks.
So just like V1,
but for hearing.
A1.
A1 also goes to another
nucleus in the thalamus.
This one called the
medial geniculate nucleus.
And then it goes from there up
through a complicated chain,
eventually-- oh, sorry,
it goes this way.
Thalamus up to A1.
So that's the basic
wiring of an adult ferret.
And so what Sur
and his colleagues
figured out how
to do is redirect
some of those connections
by surgery at birth.
So this is a wiring diagram
of the same thing shown here.
Retina, LGN.
This is V1, it's also called 17.
And here is medial geniculate
and auditory cortex.
And so what they did was
to surgically knock out
a few of these connections here
in the just-born ferret pups.
And what happens is if you
knock out this connection
here, the fibers that start
this way get rerouted,
and you end up with a ferret
that's wired up like this.
The important part of this
is this rewired ferret
has a connection between their
retina and medial geniculate
nucleus that goes to
primary auditory cortex.
So we're taking visual
input at the periphery
and wiring it up into
the auditory system.
And the point of
all of this is now,
primary auditory cortex
in this developing ferret
will be getting visual input.
And so if the input were
sufficient to determine
the function of that
region of cortex, then
what should we find in
these rewired ferrets?
What should happen in what
would have been primary auditory
cortex?
What should it do?
Christine.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] visual--
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah!
It should behave like
visual cortex, absolutely.
If everything's
determined by the inputs,
we change the inputs, it should
behave like visual cortex.
Well, that would be
freaking crazy, wouldn't it?
I mean, it's miles
away in the brain.
It's a totally
different part of brain.
That will be nuts.
But that's what happens.
It's pretty amazing.
This is a really
important study.
OK.
All right.
So what you find,
first of all, is
that primary auditory cortex
in the rewired ferrets
responds to visual input.
That's cool.
But you might say, OK, you
wired visual input in there.
Of course it's going to
respond to visual input.
So maybe that's not too
cool, but not too surprising.
But the next part is really
cool and really surprising.
Remember how I said that
in normal visual cortex--
in humans and monkeys,
and also ferrets--
you get these
orientation columns.
Now, remember, these are--
what this shows is that as you
move across the cortex in V1--
we're now talking visual
cortex here-- in visual cortex,
in normal mammals, you get
this smooth progression
of orientation selectivity as
you move across the cortex.
And that's what's shown here.
Everybody with the program?
OK.
So that's normal primary visual
cortex in an adult animal.
What do you think primary
auditory cortex looks
like in the rewired ferrets?
Damn similar.
So not only do you
get visual responses
in what would have been
auditory cortex when you rewire,
you get orientation columns.
You get this really
fine-grained structure
of what everybody
thought this was
something about visual cortex.
Well, this says
that visual input
is sufficient to produce
orientation columns
in a part of cortex
that otherwise never
would have had them.
Does everybody see how
mind-blowing this is?
OK.
So that's pretty
cool, but now we
get to the really cool question.
When these neurons are
active, does the ferret see,
or do they hear?
OK.
It's rewired.
It's getting input
from the retina,
but there's neurons
in what would
have been primary
auditory cortex now
responding to visual input.
What does the ferret
think is going on?
Does he say, oh, that's
sight, because he's
learned that visual
input means that's sight?
Or does he say,
I hear something,
because that's auditory cortex.
Everybody in the grip of
what a cool question that is?
OK.
And so it could go either way.
There's really no way
to tell in advance.
It depends on how you
read out the information
in that piece of cortex.
When we do NVPA,
we sit god-like by,
and we look at a patch of brain,
and we decode what's in there.
But really, what's
happening in the brain
is some other part of the brain
is getting input, and decoding,
and interpreting it.
And so the question is, what
do later parts of the brain
make of this?
And the answer is
the later parts
of the brain learn that
that's visual information,
and the ferret reports
seeing stuff, not hearing it.
Now, you may be thinking, how
the hell do you ask a ferret
if he's seeing or hearing?
What you do is you
use non-rewired parts
of the same ferret's brain.
Actually, forget if it's
the other hemisphere
or a different part
of the visual field
that doesn't get rewired.
So you have gold standard,
where normal vision is working,
and normal hearing is
working in the ferret,
and you train him, press
this button when you see
and press this button when you
hear, and it's unambiguous.
And then once he's trained,
you stimulate those A1 neurons
and you ask him what's going on,
and he says he sees something.
OK?
All right, so this is
one of the true classics.
OK.
So this means that A1 in this
case, primary auditory cortex,
is instructed by
its connectivity
and by the experience that
comes through that connectivity
to shape its function.
Everybody got that?
All right.
So both experience
and connectivity
can determine cortical
function, at least in ferrets.
What?
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
So first of all, what
does their V1 look
like after this rewiring, and
also, can they hear things,
and if so, where is it?
NANCY KANWISHER:
Yeah, absolutely.
OK, so if you look at the
diagram, there is additional--
well, actually, it's
not in the diagram.
But there is additional
input that's not shown here.
So they can hear things through
maybe the other hemisphere,
I forget.
They can hear.
And they can see,
because notice--
that's right.
OK, we blocked off
area 17, but these guys
are higher-level visual areas.
So they can see both through
their non-rewired hemisphere
and through some other
bypassing connections
to other parts of visual cortex.
Probably, both of those
are going to be affected.
Your vision is going to be
different if you bypass V1.
But there will be at least
some visual information.
OK, so that's ferrets.
Again, animals, you
can do invasive studies
and really do the
strong manipulation
to do a strong test
of a causal role,
and this is a classic example.
Of course, we can't
rewire humans--
or we could, but it
wouldn't be nice.
But really, we want to know,
how does all that stuff get
wired up?
Are these regions also--
is their function determined
by their connectivity
present at birth, and due
to the experience of those
regions have?
OK.
Well, we can't do controlled
rearing studies in humans.
We can't rewire their brains.
But we can be clever and smart
and think of other cases.
So here's an
important test case.
The important test case
is the case of reading.
Why reading?
Well, one, we all spend
a lot of time doing it.
And two, humans have only been
reading for a few thousand
years.
And that's not long enough
for natural selection
to have crafted an
innately-specified circuit just
for reading.
So that means that if we did
find a patch of cortex that
responds selectively to
visually-presented words,
or letters, that would suggest
that for that case at least,
experience was
sufficient to wire up,
to determine the function
of that region of cortex.
This is all very hypothetical.
Everybody got the idea?
OK.
Now, notice, this does not
apply to hearing words.
People have been hearing words
for hundreds of thousands
of years, perhaps millions.
And so that's plenty of time
for special purpose circuitry,
and that special
purpose circuitry exists
and we'll talk about
it in a month or so.
But now we're talking about
the case of visual word
recognition-- this recent
cultural invention of humans.
So that's why it's a special
case, because we know
that's too recent to be innate.
And so if we find a
selectivity, it can't be innate.
All right?
So that's what I just said.
So do we have such a thing?
Well, how would you test for it?
What would you do?
Joseph, what would you do?
You want to know if there's--
AUDIENCE: I guess I
would show them words,
and then show them
not words, and see--
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
It's not rocket science, guys.
We just keep doing
the same damn thing.
Exactly.
Right.
So start by--
here's what we did.
We showed people
visually-presented words
like that, and we showed them
line drawings of objects.
And when we did that, we
found that in most subjects,
there's a tiny little
patch of the bottom
of their left hemisphere
right near the zones
we've been talking
about, near face
selective and other regions
on the bottom of the brain.
But that tiny little patch
responds significantly more
to words than pictures.
Now, we won't do this
now, but you can do it
as a thought experiment.
What are the alternative
accounts of that activation?
Has this shown that that
region is selectively
involved in reading?
Of course not.
There's a million
differences between--
oh, come on-- these and those.
How bright they are,
how big they are.
It's a million differences.
And so to get
serious about it, we
have to do the same game
that we've been playing
all along in this course.
This is like a
first whack at it.
You find something, now
we have a candidate.
But if we want to
get serious, we've
got to test some other
conditions to see
if that's really for real.
OK?
All right.
So here's what we did in my lab
when we did this a while back.
So first of all, this
is left-out data.
Once you find that
region-- remember,
if you're trying to characterize
the function of a region,
I talked briefly
about this, a good way
to do it is to run
a localizer to find
that region in each subject.
Now we found it.
Now we have those voxels.
Now we collect some
new data that may
be a lot like our localizer.
It doesn't matter.
We collect some new data
and we look at the response.
And that just puts us on
stronger statistical footing.
OK.
So here is time going this way.
This is something called an
event-related design, where
you just present a single
stimulus, and then wait,
and another stimulus rather
than a whole bunch of them
mushed together in a block.
And then you average over
many, many repetitions.
And so this is the response
over time-- it's seconds,
it's really slow--
to words and line
drawings in that region.
So this is just replicating
what I showed you before.
It's showing you what
the actual selectivity
looks like in the real data,
not just in a significance map.
Why is this thing taking
six seconds to respond?
This is stimulus
onset out there.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: That's the
time between blood flow?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Remember, the signal
we're looking at
is based on blood flow.
The neurons all
fired right here,
but it takes a while to get
the blood flow to change.
That's why it's delayed.
Exactly.
OK.
All right.
So what else are
we going to test?
Well, you can do lots
of different things.
We just tried lots of things.
We said, OK, let's have
other things that are symbols
but that our
subjects can't read.
So we tried Chinese
characters, low response.
We tried digit strings.
Pretty low response.
That's pretty remarkable,
because words and digit strings
are pretty similar in how we use
them and what they look like.
So that's pretty good.
We tried consonant strings, like
this, that you can't pronounce.
And we got the same response.
And this is important.
It tells us this region
is not a word region.
Instead, it's something
about recognizing letters.
But for the purposes of the
current argument, that's OK.
It's still something that has
no basis in human evolution,
and so if we find selectivity
for letters that are presumably
used in the process
of reading, that
must have come from experience.
OK?
What else did we do?
OK, that's what I just said.
Now, I submit that this
is a pretty good argument
that that region must have
been wired up by experience.
But you could niggle.
You could say, well, there
are more straight edges
with the words and consonants.
The digits are
curvier, or whatever.
You could make up
some story about how
that isn't necessarily
selective for letters and words,
and therefore, maybe
it's not necessarily
wired up by experience.
Further, who knows?
Maybe everybody just has that
weird selectivity in there
even if they never
learned to read.
So it would really be nice
to make a stronger case.
And what we did was we couldn't
find people in Cambridge
who couldn't read, who didn't
have other things going on,
but we could find people
who did read Hebrew.
And we had-- where's
my Hebrew data?
All right, hang on.
OK, right.
So here are our
non-Hebrew readers.
This is funny.
This is an old graph.
It's not so impressive-looking.
This is-- I forgot to
switch out our newer data.
OK, so what we found is in
people who don't read Hebrew,
the response was lower
to Hebrew than to words.
Looks like it's almost
as high, actually.
When we ran more subjects, it's
actually quite a bit lower.
Nonetheless, when
we ran people who
read both English and Hebrew,
the Hebrew response is higher.
And that nails the case that
it's actually that individual's
experience that determines the
selectivity of this region.
It depends on what
orthographies you know.
If you know how to read Hebrew,
you get a high response.
If you don't, you
get a lower response.
Everybody get that this
pretty much nails the case?
OK, so where are we?
All of this was
to say, do we ever
see selectivity in the
brain that can't be innate?
And I submit to you, this is
selectivity in the brain that
can't be innate, that
has to be learned.
And in fact, our data
show that it depends
on the subject's experience.
OK.
So-- good.
So yes, we have such a thing.
It's called the
visual word form area.
Now, what about this idea that
connectivity of that region
is playing a role-- it's in
a very systematic location.
It's that little orange
thing right there.
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: Question.
I'm just trying to think
through the alternative.
The brain has to be
shaped by experience,
otherwise you would never
learn anything, right?
NANCY KANWISHER: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Even if this
didn't show that difference,
it would just mean
the difference is
something you're not measuring.
NANCY KANWISHER:
Absolutely, absolutely.
You wouldn't be able to
understand the sentence I'm
saying right now without
changing your brain,
because by the time you get
to the end of the sentence,
you need to remember what
I said at the beginning
of the sentence, so there's
little things structurally
wiggling around in
your brain and changing
synaptic connectivity
online all the time
or you wouldn't be able to
think, let alone remember.
Absolutely.
So the question here
is more specific.
It's not whether the brain
changes with experience.
Absolutely, it does.
It's whether experience can
explain these particular cell
activities and where
they came from.
I'm glad you asked
that question.
OK.
OK, so now, we've just
argued that the selectivity
of that little dot, at least,
must be due to experience.
Doesn't tell us
about the others,
but tells us that one must be.
And now we're asking,
can its selectivity--
can that location be
determined by the connectivity
of that region?
So to get to that, we use
diffusion tractography.
And the hypothesis
here is that it's
these long-range connections
that determine where
those functional regions land.
This is me with a bunch of
functional regions in my head.
Doesn't matter which ones.
We're just asking
the general question.
And so I'm going to skip
over all the details,
but just give you the
gist of a recent paper
that we published
looking at this.
We asked-- we found the
visual word form area.
That's right down in there,
about there, left hemisphere.
And we scanned kids at age
eight and age five, same kids.
Age five, then age eight.
Here's the age eight data.
These kids have learned to
read in between the two scans.
And here is the response
of their visual word form
area to words, faces, objects,
and scrambled objects.
Nice and selective, just
like a good visual word form
area should respond.
So it's there by age eight.
What we then do is we take
the data in the same kid
across those three years,
align the data, and say,
what were those voxels doing
in that kid at age five
before they learned to read?
This is another way
of showing that it's
experience that was necessary.
And boom, they were
not word selective.
They shouldn't be.
These kids hadn't
learned to read yet.
But it's still kind of nice
to be able to show that.
All right?
But now, the
hypothesis is that it's
the connectivity at age
five that predicts where
this region is going to land.
So we use that same
rigmarole that I showed you
earlier for adults, where
we used just diffusion data
to predict where the
functional region will arise.
But we use the diffusion
data from five-year-olds
to predict where
that region would
arise when the kids were eight.
And it turns out
you can do that.
You can predict actually
fine-grained individual
differences in exactly
where the visual word form
area will arise at age
eight from that same kid's
connectivity at age five.
So does everybody
see how that fits
one of the necessary
conditions for this idea
that the locations where
these things land later
in development is
determined by connectivity
that exists before?
Now, our study was
done in humans,
so we didn't have a causal test.
All we can say is it was there
before, and it's sufficient.
But we don't know if that's
actually how it worked.
That's how it is
working on humans.
But if you put it together
with the ferret data,
it's pretty suggestive.
All right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where is
it connected to?
NANCY KANWISHER: Ah.
Very good question.
I'm being very
vague, connectivity.
This is a long,
complicated issue.
Most likely, it's connected to
language-y areas, which we'll
talk about in a
month or so, that
are out on the lateral surface
and up in the frontal lobe.
There are papers
claiming that it's
connected to language-y areas.
But I'm kind of a
methodological hard ass,
and I don't quite
believe those data.
I mean, I think they
have a medium case,
but they haven't nailed it.
I've tried to nail it.
It's hard for all of the
reasons that this method
that I was complaining about--
I'm complaining about it
because I'm bitter about it.
I want this method to be better.
I want to know what those actual
structural connections are.
I wish we could put a seed
in the visual word form area
and follow those
tracks and say not just
there's enough of a
fingerprint that we
can predict its function, but
here are the exact connections.
And it's, mm, not quite up
to that task, in my view.
It's a big bummer.
I've wasted a lot of the last
year trying to get that method
to work, and I haven't quite
given up yet, but I'm close.
It's OK.
It's just not good enough to
answer those questions, which
is very frustrating because
they're pressing questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
one more question?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So people
who are blind shouldn't
have this region active.
NANCY KANWISHER: Ooh,
very interesting question.
What do you think?
People who are blind read.
AUDIENCE: So the connection
between here and the visual
system for the blind people goes
from that region and touching,
since they're--
I don't know.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Yeah, it's not obvious.
It's not obvious.
There are several papers--
which I was going to
put in this lecture
and I just couldn't fit.
But there are
several papers that
argue that tactile Braille
reading in congenitally
blind people activates
that same region.
They're pretty good papers.
I sort of believe it.
I have-- as I say, I'm a
little bit of a hard ass,
so I'm not 100% convinced,
but they're pretty compelling,
and it's a very
interesting question.
And it's a whole saga.
It's so interesting.
I'm going to try
to incorporate more
of this in a later lecture,
because I didn't fit it
in here.
Yeah.
And the idea would
be, if you had
to guess, what will those
connections be that drive that?
Certainly not visual input.
They're not getting
visual input.
So it would have to be input
from language-y regions
or something like
that, that would also
be present in blind people.
See what I mean?
OK.
All right.
Anyway, all of this just
to say that it looks
like the visual
word form area is
kind of special
in the human brain
because, one, it shows us
that at least one region gets
its selectivity from
experience, and two,
because it develops later,
it gave us this opportunity
to ask if the connectivity was
present before the function
as a sort of weak test of this
hypothesis that connectivity
determines function.
All right.
Boom.
All right, so where are we?
This really is a shaggy
dog story lecture.
OK.
So we started off by saying
a lot of the basic structure
of the brain is innate.
Most of the neurons in your
brain, you had at birth.
Most of the
long-range connections
were present at birth.
They weren't yet myelinated,
but they were there.
We've argued that some of these
selective cortical regions
appear to depend on experience.
For example, the
face-deprived monkeys
don't have face patches.
And the ferrets see the
response of an auditory cortex
when their auditory
cortex has been
rewired to get visual input.
And further, I've argued
that the visual word form
area, the selectivity of
that region can't be innate,
and yet it arises at
a consistent location,
possibly because of these
long-range connections
of that region.
So all of this looks
very experiential,
aside from the structural
stuff that's present at birth.
So is Kant toast?
I started last
lecture as saying he
was reacting against
the empiricist,
saying not everything is
derived from experience.
We need to have a priori
conditions of cognition.
Remember, he said,
"space can be given
prior to all actual perceptions,
and so exist in the mind
a priori.
And it can contain, prior to
all experience, principles
which determine the
relations of these objects."
So he's basically saying we
have an innate representation
of space.
And I've just been giving
you all this evidence
for all the other cases
that experience seems
to be playing the major role.
So is it all over for Kant?
Well, actually, Kant was talking
about space and time primarily,
and we haven't
considered that yet.
So let's get back to space.
Remember these spatial
representations
that I talked about
in the rodent brain.
Four different kinds
of neurons that
are present in adult rodents
that play wonderfully
different roles in navigation.
Remember, there are place
cells that fire only
when the rodent is in a given
known place in his environment.
There are direction
cells that fire only
when the rodent is
oriented in a given
direction in his environment.
There are border
cells that fire only
when the rodent is near a
border of the space he's in,
like right now,
I have cells that
are firing because I'm next
to this border of this space
that I'm in, and Anna does not
have any of those cells firing
because she's in the
middle of this space.
And there are grid cells that
have this amazing property
of firing in a hexagonal
array of little micro place
cells spaced evenly
in a hexagonal array.
OK, so all of this apparatus
that I talked about last time
that seems to be playing a role
in your concept of where you
are, where you're oriented,
and the space around you,
if we had to take some
representation of space
that Kant might have
been talking about,
this would be it.
So is this stuff innate?
Well, happily, all this work
was done originally in rodents.
All the most detailed
work was done in rodents,
so we can ask that question,
because it's an animal.
OK?
All right.
So what the Mosers
and their colleagues--
the husband-wife team who
got the Nobel Prize in 2014
for their work on
the grid cells--
and O'Keefe and their
colleagues in London,
who discovered place
cells in the first place--
two different groups
simultaneously realized what
a huge, big, fabulous
question this was,
and they both did the
experiment at the same time,
and they published it together
at the same time about four
years ago in--
I forget-- Science or Nature.
Big event in the field.
So they both realize
the same thing.
The way rodents grow up,
they hang out in a dark nest.
They're very premature at birth,
and they can't really do much.
They can't move around.
All they can do
is turn their head
toward a nipple and suck milk.
That's kind of it.
And so there they are,
in the nest, in the dark.
Their eyes don't even
open until the end
of the second week of life.
And at the same time,
it's the first time
they emerge from the
nest, and the first time
they have any experience
navigating, any real experience
of space.
And so we can ask
which of those cells
are present, the very
first experience.
And it turns out that--
sorry, this is a
little hard to see.
There's a light yellow overlay.
This is the window when
they first open their eyes
and leave the nest,
between postnatal day
12 and 14, the end of
the second week of life.
And what you see is the
head direction cells are
present immediately, as
soon as the-- can first
collect neurophysiology data
from these newborn rat pups.
They're there right away.
Place cells, you can
get them pretty early,
and grid cells soon after that.
So this suggests that in
the rodents, at least,
their representation
of space as entailed
in the properties of these
neurons is largely innate.
So just like Kant said
way back in the 1700s.
Everybody get this?
It's pretty cool.
It's a rare opportunity
where you can just
take a huge, big
philosophical question
and, boom, answer it with data.
Yeah.
Awesome.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Wait, sorry--
NANCY KANWISHER: I'm
sorry, is it Martin?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, are you
saying that it's innate
or that it's learned?
NANCY KANWISHER: Innate.
Innate.
AUDIENCE: --takes time--
NANCY KANWISHER:
Because-- oh, yeah.
OK, important point.
OK, we don't know before
then whether they existed.
They were in the nest.
You can't really
do neurophysiology
on the rodents in the nest.
The point is, none of
the relevant experience
has happened before then.
They haven't opened their
eyes, they haven't navigated.
So none of the
experience that could
be relevant for navigation has
happened before right here,
on the very first time
that you can test it,
and the very first time
that they could possibly
be in the world, seeing
the world, navigating,
they have them.
But what you point to
is an important point.
I mentioned this
briefly last time,
but it's really worth repeating.
Innate-- I guess the
word "innate" can
be used different ways, but
what I mean by innate here,
the relevant part of innate, the
content to the big questions,
is whether it's
specified at birth, not
whether it exists at birth.
Remember, I gave
the case of puberty.
Puberty happens way
after birth, but it's not
the result of experience.
It's part of a genetic program.
It's just going to happen.
I mean, I guess if you don't
eat anything, you'll die
and then it won't happen,
but within broad latitude,
it's not the result
of experience.
And so you can have maturation
on a biological autopilot that
continues independent
of experience,
and that's the relevant
kind of innate.
I realize I was
probably confusing.
Innate for this purpose
doesn't mean present at birth.
It means determined
at birth, essentially,
independent of experience.
Good.
You guys are asking
good questions
and it's helping me be clearer.
OK.
OK, so that's cool.
That says that
those cells are all
present very early on,
and presumably independent
of experience.
What about re-orientation?
Remember, re-orientation
is this cool thing
that I carried on
for a long time about
because it's so interesting.
Reorientation is this
particular aspect
of the navigation system.
It's been studied behaviorally
in rodents, in young humans,
and human adults.
And lots of other
animals, actually.
And the key thing
about reorientation
is this is how an animal
gets their bearing when
they're disoriented.
And the key finding is they use
the shape of space around them.
They don't use landmarks
to reorient themselves.
That's the key finding.
This is all stuff I
talked about before.
And the evidence that animals
use the shape of space
to reorient is, when you have
shown a rodent that there's
goodies in that corner, the
left side of the short wall,
essentially, and then you
disorient him and put him back
in the box, he goes 50/50
to those two corners,
showing that he's
learned something
like the food is on the
left side of the short wall.
Not in words, presumably,
but some mental language
that holds that information.
OK, so that's using the shape
of space for reorientation.
Is that ability to use
the shape of space--
this is a different
sense of space
than head direction cells, the
shape of space around you--
is that present
independent of experience?
Well, again, we can't
test that in humans
because we can't deprive
humans of experiencing
the shape of space around them.
Was there a question?
No?
OK, all right.
But we can test it in
animals with something
called controlled rearing
that I've talked about before.
So again, we can't test
this-- even in animals,
it's hard to test at birth.
Lots of animals can't navigate
very well at birth, right?
So we want to test
them after birth,
but we don't want them to
have the relevant experience,
because that's
what we're asking,
is would this
ability be there even
without the relevant experience.
OK.
So the answer to all of
this, the way around this
is to use controlled rearing.
Just like Sugita did with
the face-deprived monkeys,
and just like our Carl also did
with face-deprived monkeys--
the behavioral study and
the functional MRI study.
But this will be a
controlled rearing
study in a different organism,
and it's pretty cute.
It goes like this.
This is a group
in Italy that has
a whole lab that
uses this paradigm,
and it's very, very powerful.
So what they do is they--
again, I just said this.
The whole idea is
raise an animal
without the relevant
experience, figure out
if the ability arises anyway.
So in this case,
what they do is they
get fertilized eggs, chicken
eggs from a local hatchery
that's conveniently
near their lab.
They bring those fertilized
eggs into the lab
and put them in an incubator,
and they hatch them
in darkness.
Then for the first few days,
you get a nice little chicken.
It's in the light here, but
that's just so you can see it.
It actually hatches
in the darkness,
so there's no visual experience.
Then you put them in
cages of different shapes.
Either a nice rectangular
shape like this
that would be relevant
for reorienting,
or a circular space like that
that has no geometric cues
because it's symmetrical.
So they spend their first
three days of life in one
or the other of
those containers.
You then, in order to get a
behavioral result out of them,
you have to use their
natural behavior, which is
that they imprint on mama bird.
And you may know that imprinting
is pretty non-specific.
Baby birds will imprint on
nearly anything that moves.
So they take a big,
red plastic object,
and they dangle it in
the middle of the cage,
and little chicks
follow the red object.
That's mom.
That's what they do.
So then you can use that
behavior to test their ability.
And so you get
them in the groove.
You show them mom, and mom
disappears behind an occluder.
And then you let the
chick go follow mom,
which the chick wants to do.
So they do a few
trials like that.
They've imprinted.
They're going to follow mom.
This gives us a way
to ask the chick,
where do you think mom is?
And that gives us
a way to ask, what
cues are you using to reorient,
even though you've been raised
without geometric information.
All right.
And the thing I really
love about this--
oh, I guess it's
on a later slide--
is that after you do
the whole experiment,
you take one or two
trials on that chick,
you're done with
that chick, they
have the relevant
experience, you give them
back to the hatchery and the
hatchery does their thing.
So it's just like a really
nice little symbiotic
science-farming enterprise.
OK, so here's
actually what they do.
So here's how the
re-orientation test goes.
After this chick is raised in
one of those two environments--
the circular one with no
geometric information,
or the rectangular one with
geometric information--
and they've learned to
follow big red plastic mom,
you then put the chick
in this box here.
The chick is in there
in this wire mesh
that holds them in there
so he can't run around.
He's in this rectangular
space, and there
are four symmetrical
occluders in the corner.
You then take the red object--
mom-- and hide it behind
one of the blue panels
in full view of the chick.
So now the chick
knows where mom is.
Now you bring down
an opaque cylinder
around where the chick is.
And while the opaque
cylinder is down,
you rotate the box 90 degrees.
So now, the chick has no way
to tell things are rotated,
I'm disoriented, what's what,
how do I know where to go.
So this is reorientation in
a newly-hatched chick that's
been reared under
controlled conditions.
All right.
So now, once you rotate
the box, then you
lift up the opaque
occluder, and the cage,
and you see where
the chick goes.
Everybody get this?
It's a little bit convoluted.
But it's just a version--
it's a chick version of the
same reorientation task we've
been talking about all along.
You do 16 trials, and then
you give the chick back
to the hatchery.
OK.
So here's what happens
for chicks that are raised
in that rectangular cage.
They have geometric experience
during those first three
days of life.
So this is kind
of a control case.
And what you find
is that when you've
hid mom in a corner that
is on the right side
of the short wall,
they go preferentially
to the two corners
consistent with that more
than the other two corners,
consistent with the idea
that they can use geometric
information to reorient
themselves.
They're not perfect, but
they're way better than chance.
Does that make sense?
They go to the two corners
that are consistent,
showing that they can use
the geometric information.
But these are the
chicks that were raised
with the geometric experience.
What about the chicks
raised in the cylinder,
without geometric experience?
They do the same thing.
And this is the first
time they've experienced--
this testing condition is the
first time they've experienced
any space that
isn't symmetrical,
any place where
they could possibly
use geometric
information to orient,
and they do it on
the first trials.
Everybody got that?
So that tells us
that this ability
to reorient based on
the shape of space
when you're disoriented
doesn't require experience
with the geometry of space.
Now, you might be thinking,
well, that cylindrical cage,
it doesn't have something
to break the symmetry,
but there's still
something geometric.
There's a floor, there's a wall.
I agree, that bugged me too.
They did another experiment in
which they raised the chicks
in total darkness.
First three days, no
visual experience at all,
and the chicks still do that.
So no visual experience.
That's an even stronger case.
Was there a question
percolating in here?
I felt like-- no, OK.
All right.
So yes, the reorientation
system-- actually,
that's not well expressed.
The ability to use
geometry to reorient
is not based on any
experience with geometry.
It must be innate in the sense
of not requiring experience.
So go Kant.
All right.
So where have we gotten to?
Let's recap.
What's innate?
OK, in the face system--
I went through this before,
maybe not that much.
We could quibble some of
the cases are ambiguous,
but the main evidence
suggests that--
before you posit that
something's innate,
it's like the
evidence-- you have
to have strong evidence for
innateness to argue with.
The default case is
not innate, right?
It's kind of an extreme
claim, and so the default
is not innate, and so right now,
we don't have a strong argument
that any of the face system
is innate other than this bias
to look more at
faces, which as I said
might be a very
rudimentary template.
OK.
I talked about the role of
connectivity and cortical
development.
Most of those
long-range connections
are present at birth.
I showed that connectivity can
causally affect development
in the case of the
rewired ferrets.
I showed that category selective
regions in human adults
have distinctive connectivity.
And I showed that in the
visual word form area,
the distinctive connectivity
is present before the function.
OK.
So that tells us that there's
one region in the brain
that we know the selectivity
of that region can't be innate.
It doesn't tell us
about all the others.
Who knows?
It's kind of an existence proof.
They might all be
learned by experience.
We look at faces a lot.
We look at scenes a lot.
We look at bodies a lot.
Maybe they all have the
same experiential basis.
Doesn't prove it.
It just says maybe.
All right.
But then I showed that for
the space system, actually,
we do have pretty strong
evidence that a lot of it
is innate, both in
that the head direction
cells are present before
any visual experience
or any navigation.
And I showed that the
chicks can reorient
based on the geometry of
space, even if they've never
seen space or geometry before.
So bottom line, face
system, who knows,
but no strong evidence
for innateness.
Visual word form
area, strong evidence
that it's experientially
based, and space
system, strong evidence
that a lot of it is innate.
OK.
All right.
I got us to here.
Now, all of this time,
I've been talking about,
how do we wire up this system
and its cognitive correlates
in development?
What do you have to build
in to get a system like this
in development?
What can you get
through learning?
What do you have to
build in, and so forth.
But it's a related but
different question to ask,
is that the only possible
way it could work,
or are there situations
where we might
have a very different kind
of organization of the brain?
Are there other
possible organizations
that might develop under
different circumstances that
would still work?
And the two relevant cases
that people have looked at
are cases of brain damage.
So if you have brain
damage in adulthood,
and you lose a little
piece, can that piece
move over and reorganize?
Is there another possible
organization that would work?
Or what about if
you have very, very
different visual experience,
like you're born blind.
Then do you get the
same organization,
or does everything go
haywire and you have
a totally different kind
of brain organization?
All right, so I'll give
you a little bit of data
on each of those questions.
All right.
So first of all, can the brain
reorganize after brain damage?
The main domain where
people have studied this--
which we haven't talked about
yet, but we will in a month--
is the case of language.
So it's just something there
are lots of studies of this.
People have been onto this
question for a long time.
In fact, Broca wrote about
this question 200 years ago.
So the basic findings are
that if you have damage
to your language parts of
your brain in adulthood,
that is not good.
Often, you'll recover a
little bit of function,
but you really
won't get it back.
It's just a big massive drag.
There are people we will
talk about in a month
when we get to the
language section who
have had massive left hemisphere
strokes that basically take out
their entire language system.
And it doesn't come back
years after that stroke.
We'll see, actually, that
they're cognitively pretty
normal in every other respect.
It's quite amazing how much
they can do without language,
which is fascinating.
But for present purposes,
the main finding
is brain damage in
adulthood that takes out
language functions, not good.
Not much recovery, not
much reorganization.
By the way, there's
a whole-- it's
very trendy in popular media
to talk about, oh, the brain is
plastic, you can
rewire your brain,
take this-- use this smartphone
app and rewire your brain.
Mostly, that stuff
is just bullshit.
You can learn a task,
and you can get better
at that task, no question.
But you can't make
yourself smarter.
You can't rewire
your whole brain.
That's garbage.
All right.
Back to aphasia.
OK.
The story is very different
for brain damage in kids.
If you have brain damage in
the first few months of life
to language parts of
the brain, as an adult,
your language function
is pretty good.
It's not quite perfect.
Took people a while to discover
that it isn't quite perfect,
but it's surprisingly good.
For everyday uses, you
might not even notice.
You have to test people on
esoteric syntactic things
to discover that, actually,
it's not quite right.
But it's very good.
And typically, what you
see, if you scan these kids,
is that a lot of
language function
has reorganized and shifted
over to homologous regions
in the right hemisphere.
OK, so that's better news.
After age five, if you have
brain damage, not so good.
So it's like there's
some critical period
for when the brain is plastic.
You can move language over
to the right hemisphere up
until around age five, and
after that, you can't really.
All right, so these consider--
right, that's what I just said.
So these considerations
have been pulled together
under something called
the Kennard Principle.
And the Kennard
Principle basically
says, if you're going to have
brain damage, have it early.
Better not to have
the brain damage,
but if you have to
have it, have it early.
And that's based on
findings like this--
the fact that the kids who
have left hemisphere damage
have much better
language function
as adults than adults
who have the same kind
of left hemisphere damage.
OK, so that's a
reasonable summary
of the language literature.
However, this finding
doesn't always hold.
And it has led others to put
forth the Hebb Principle, which
is sort of the opposite.
The idea of the Hebb Principle
is that, first of all,
it depends.
It depends on where
the damage is.
It depends on when you
test after brain damage.
But the key insight that will
make this seem more sensible--
at first, you feel like
it's very intuitive.
Kids are more plastic in
all kinds of ways, right?
Watch me using a computer,
it drives my students insane,
I'm so slow.
One of my students once--
back when I used to
actually scan subjects,
one of my students
was watching me scan,
and he's just getting
more and more impatient,
and he finally is like, it's
like watching my mother.
It's just like, you cannot
become as fluent at things when
you start doing
it when you're 50.
It's just what it is.
We've all seen that
manifest in various ways.
OK, so that's generally
true, and that's
consistent with this
Kennard principles
that you have more flexibility
when you're younger than older,
which is also why you guys
should learn lots of math
and computer science now
while your brains are still
good at it.
Don't wait until you're
40 when it's harder.
You will need it.
No matter what field
you are in, you
will need it, so
do all of that now.
OK.
But to get back to
the topic at hand,
what is the idea behind
the Hebb principle?
The idea is, think
about building a house.
You can't build the
first floor if you
haven't built the foundation.
Similarly, you might
imagine that there
are lots of aspects
of cognition that
are necessary precursors for
other aspects of cognition.
And if you're wiring
up a whole brain,
you're not going to develop
those second order ones if you
don't get the first order ones.
And so if you have
damage early in life,
you may have bigger
long-term consequences.
Really concrete kind
of silly example.
Suppose you have damage
to primary auditory cortex
at birth, and you're deaf.
Well, you're going to have a
harder time learning language
because you need to
hear to get language.
I mean, if you
have smart parents,
they'll teach you sign
language, you'll be OK.
But this is a necessary
prior condition.
And so more generally, it turns
out that in a lot of domains,
some aspects of
brain and cognition
are necessary precursors for
others, and in those cases,
the Kennard Principle
doesn't hold.
OK?
Blah, blah, blah.
OK, now let's get--
this is all sort
of in-principle vague stuff.
OK, what about visual cortex?
What about all this stuff
we've been talking about here?
All of these specialized
regions for different features
and different
categories, and you
may notice I've now added
visually-presented words
on there.
Remember, visually-presented,
not auditorily.
Auditory is a whole
different thing.
This is seeing
words and letters.
OK, so all of this organization,
can this stuff move around?
If you lose this thing, can
you regrow it over there?
Well, not really.
As I've been talking
about, if you
have brain damage in
adulthood, you basically
lose the corresponding
mental function.
That's why we have all these
neuropsychological syndromes.
If people could relearn and
just move the function over,
you wouldn't have a syndrome.
You might have a transient
problem as you relearned.
But in fact, if people
get achromatopsia--
can't see color vision--
they're not going to
get better, or not much.
Agnosia, if they
can't see shape,
they're not going to get better.
Akinetopsia, they
can't see motion
after a stroke in adulthood.
They're not going to get better.
Prosopagnosia, topographic
disorientation, and alexia--
inability to read due
to a stroke-- basically,
people don't really
recover from these things.
There's a beautiful
recent article
by a German neuroscientist
who had a stroke
and couldn't read at--
I don't know-- age 50,
60, something like that.
And so made himself an
experimental subject,
and was just determined
to relearn to read.
And he did every
possible thing, and he's
written about this
very interestingly,
and there's an article
I can put on the website
if anybody wants to read it.
He basically retaught
himself to read,
but he's doing it in
completely different ways
from what all of you are doing.
He doesn't have that bit.
He didn't develop
a new one of those.
He developed a very different
compensatory strategy that's
very slow and doesn't
work anywhere near
as well as reading
does for any of us.
So basically, in adulthood,
these things can't move around.
So now, are we talking Kennard
or are we talking Hebb?
What happens if you get
the damage in childhood?
Well, I'm raising this
question because I
think it's big, and
deep, and interesting,
but there basically isn't
much of an answer to it.
It's hard to answer.
I'll give you just
a shred of data,
but basically, I think
we don't know the answer,
and I'm dying to
know the answer.
I'll give you just the
one paper that I know
of that's relevant to this.
This is a study from
quite a while ago.
It's the case of a
patient who's known
in the literature as Adam.
And Adam sustained
bilateral damage
to his ventral visual
pathway, both sides,
at day one of age
due to a stroke.
Actually, strokes around
birth are surprisingly common,
like this happens.
So this guy basically lost
cortex in a lot of the regions
that we've been talking about
on the bottom of the brain that
do high-level vision.
OK, so he was tested for
this study at age 16.
Now, his visual
acuity, his ability
to see fine-grained
stuff is not great,
and his object recognition
is not perfect,
but it's not terrible either.
He can recognize common objects
from photographs and line
drawings reasonably well.
So he has some residual vision.
But he can't recognize
faces at all.
So he is a fan of this TV
series called Baywatch,
which I don't know about.
I don't know if that's
like-- anyway, this study was
done a long time ago.
Anyway, some beach
TV series that
has the same set of characters,
and he was obsessed with this,
and he watched it
for an hour every day
for a year and a half.
And that's just
relevant because we
know that he has
lots of experience
looking at these individuals.
But when tested in the lab
on pictures from Baywatch,
he couldn't recognize any
of the major protagonists.
That's just a measure of how
severely prosopagnosic he was.
So that suggests that when the
relevant parts of the brain,
that the relevant parts are
already specified at birth,
and if you lose those parts,
you can't just put that function
somewhere else.
So that suggests-- I'm not
leaning too hard on this
because there's just
very little data.
This is the best there is.
So it suggests that those--
at least the general region
is already specified.
Can anybody think about
why that might be?
Why can't you just train up
some other part of cortex?
Say, his object
recognition is pretty good.
Why can't you train that part
of the object recognition system
and just say, OK,
learn to do faces?
Nobody knows the answer to this.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
about the [INAUDIBLE]
it's gone completely, just
maybe because throughout time
very far back in evolution,
it's a face region.
NANCY KANWISHER: Yeah.
Yes, but still-- yeah, I mean,
it's clear that we have it,
and we probably have it for
some reason and all of that.
But why couldn't you
just grow a new one over
in a different part of cortex?
What's wrong with that
other bit of cortex?
What might it not have
that you might need.
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: The right connection?
NANCY KANWISHER: Yes!
I just showed you
guys that there are
very distinctive connections.
This is all speculation.
Nobody knows why.
I'm just saying
that one guess is
that the reason these
things can't just take up
residence someplace
else is they need
those particular connections to
get the right input to process.
OK, anyway, this is going
way beyond the data.
But in principle, people could
get more data of this kind
and answer this question.
If I can find the
relevant subjects,
I'm aiming to do this.
OK, so let's take
one other case.
Very different kind of
change to ask, what happens--
so basically, bottom
line of all of this
is, stuff doesn't
move around that much.
Early brain damage
to language regions,
they can shift to the
homologous regions
in the right hemisphere.
But all the other
data that I know of
suggests you can't just
take anything and move it
around a few centimeters over.
At least if you have
the damage in adulthood,
and maybe even if you
have it pretty early.
OK, all right.
So now we're going to say,
OK, might this organization
nonetheless be very
different if you
had very different experience?
So let's take the case
of congenital blindness.
OK, so how is the
brain organized
in congenital blindness?
Well, let's take V1.
Here's this big chunk of
cortex back here, nice
big chunk of cortex that, in
all of you guys, does vision.
What does it do in
congenitally blind people?
Does it just sit there?
Do the cells die out?
Do they just go
dum-dee-dum-dee-dum and they
don't do anything?
It's a lot of cortex to
waste on all of that.
Well, it turns
out, astonishingly,
that what visual cortex
does in blind people
is a whole bunch
of other things,
including,
astonishingly, language.
So you present a sentence
to subjects through Braille
or auditorily to blind
subjects in the scanner,
and you see activation of V1.
Further, you might think,
well, OK, whatever.
Just turns on, it has
nothing to do with anything.
But TMS studies-- V1 is right
near the surface of the brain.
You can zap that region and ask
if you're disrupting function,
and you can interfere
with language task
by zapping V1 in
congenitally blind people.
So it's not just activated.
It's doing causal
work in blind people.
This is mind-blowing.
This is like a totally
different patch of cortex.
So yeah, it's hard to think
of more different functions
than low-level vision and
high-level abstract language
processing.
So that suggests radical
possible reorganization,
in this case, with
different experience.
OK, what about those regions
on the bottom surface
of the brain?
The face, place,
word, and body regions
that we've been talking
about for so long.
What do they do in blind people?
Somebody already asked me
before, maybe [INAUDIBLE]..
Somebody over there.
It's my spatial code.
And there's a lot
of claims that they
have similar selectivity,
which I'm not totally sure of,
but let me show you
one piece of data.
I promised you that
there were going
to be further contradictions
in the whole saga of the role
of experience in wiring
up these regions,
so here's one more
contradictory piece of data.
OK, this is a paper that was
published just a few months
ago, and the title of the
paper is that the development
of visual category selectivity--
that means face place body
regions, all that stuff--
in the ventral visual
cortex does not
require visual experience.
OK.
What?
What, what, what?
OK, here's what they did.
They scanned-- pretty
crazy experiment--
they scanned congenitally
blind subjects while they heard
sounds that were associated
with faces, bodies, objects,
and scenes.
So for example, they might
hear laughing, chewing, blowing
a kiss, whistling sounds.
Those are face-related sounds.
Or they might hear scratching,
hand-clapping, finger-snapping,
bare footsteps,
knuckle cracking.
Those are body-related
sounds, et cetera.
So they're lying in the
scanner hearing these sounds.
Probably cracking up.
Now the question is, do
we see face, place, body,
and object regions
activated from sounds
in congenitally blind
people listening
to those categories of sounds?
And the crazy answer is,
kind of sort of a little bit.
It's not super strong.
The data are not
mind-blowing, but let
me just show you what we have.
OK, this is the bottom of
the brain, back of the brain.
Everybody oriented here?
OK.
Occipital lobe.
This is where all
the good stuff is
that we've been talking about.
OK.
So this is now the
sighted control subjects
looking at visual stimuli.
So this is a significant
map, P levels.
And so what you see is
facial activity in red,
object selectivity in
green, scene selectivity
in blue, purple,
whatever that is-- blue.
So that should look
sort of familiar.
Faces, lateral, scenes, medial.
Objects, people debate about.
I haven't talked about it
much, because-- anyway, faces
and scenes, so stuff
to pay attention to.
OK.
And over here-- this
map is the same.
It just says, never mind
if that voxel reaches
statistical significance.
Just plot what category
that voxel responds most to.
So you just see a big swath.
All right.
Now, what do we see for
sighted controls listening
to the auditory stimuli?
Not much reaches significance.
If you drop the threshold
way down and look at this,
maybe a little bit.
These are somewhat
correlated, but it's lousy.
So sighted subjects listening
to those sounds, not much.
What do you think happens
with blind subjects listening
to those sounds?
Well, you get face
selectivity here
that's statistically
significant.
And if you drop the threshold
and look at the overall map,
you see a resemblance
of this map
to the sighted map, the visual
map in the sighted subjects,
and this correlation
is highly significant.
So this is totally weird.
It says, yes, there's a
similar spatial layout
on the brain of these same
selectivities in congenitally
blind subjects who
never saw those stimuli.
And that's the basis
of their argument,
that the development of
visually category selectivity
doesn't require experience.
But now you may be thinking,
what about that paper
on face-deprived monkeys?
The title of which
is, "Seeing faces
is necessary for
face-domain formation,"
namely for face patches.
So these two findings, these
two claims in the titles
are completely contradictory.
So we're out of time.
Nobody knows the answer to this.
It's an ongoing puzzle.
There are all kinds
of possibilities.
They're different
species, they're
different kinds of tests.
There are many
things you could say,
but we're really right on
the horn of a big conundrum
in the field.
And all I have to say is
welcome to the cutting edge.
It's a mess there.
OK, thank you.